عن طريق نهر النيل يصل النازحون
السودانيون الى مدينه ابو سمبل بعد عبورهم
من معبر قسطنب البري الوجوه المرهقه من
عناء الرحله الطويله تبتسم اخيرا مع
استقبال اهالي اخر مدينه على الحدود
المصريه الجنوبيه السكان يتجمعون حاملين
ما تيسر من طعام وشراب لتقديمه لاهالي
السودان قبل استئناف رحلتهم الى مدينه
اسوان احنا طبعا لازم نقف جنب شقاءنا
سودانيين في الازمه اللي هم فيها واحنا
عملنا المبادره دي مع شباب القريه عندنا
اهل البلد يعني يعني الخدمه اللي قدموها
لنا ما حسستني انه لسه مازلنا في السودان
يعني بعض القادمين لا يملكون الاموال
اللازمه لاستكمال الرحله احدى المجموعات
النازحه توجهت الى وسط المدينه لتفاجا برد
فعل الاهالي الذين قاموا بجمع المساعدات
المطلوبه
والله انا يعني سمي ده ما نزل مو سمبل
وانا سنابل
الكرم ولقينا الضيافه ولقينا منهم والله
كل خير يعني
وابناء وقفوا مع بعض وجبنا
اللبن للاطفال وببرونها للاطفال
وبامبرز للاطفال جبناهم مستشفى ابو سمبل
يعمل على قدم الوثائق لاستقبال النازحين
موفرين لهم ما يحتاجونه من دواء واسعافات
من كل الهيئات الصحيه سواء تامين شامل
سواء وزاره الصحه حتى برضو لقينا برضو
مساعدات من جهات تانيه ففضل الله محدش
مقصر يعني
ورغم اصراري اغلب من ياتون الى ابو سمبل
لاستكمال رحلاتهم لمدينه اسوان فان
مستقبليهم يصرون على دعوتهم للمبيت في
بيوتهم للراحه من وعثاء السفر الطويل سكان
ابو سمبل يؤكدون دائما بان السودان يمثل
لهم امتدادا ليس جغرافيا فقط ولكن انسانيا
ايضا كلمات وشعارات برهنت الاحداث على مدى
مصداقيتها احمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات